l'UDI en marge depuis le mois de
septembre et avant même que le président
départemental souhaite élu le 6 juin
prochain l'UDI jeune se met à son tour
en place autour de deux co animateurs le
but rassembler largement des Jeunes
Centristes aux Jeunes Démocrates en
passant par les radicaux la Gauche
moderne ou l'Alliance centriste en ligne
de mire les Européennes et les
municipales les municipales comme une
formation jeune en politique c'est une
école de la vie politique donc l'idée à
travers un parti jeune c'est de former
les jeunes à cette activité citoyenne
donc effectivement on va avoir une vraie
volonté de placer le plus de jeunes qui
sont investis et implantés dans des
communes sur des listes pour commencer à
appréhender le débat le débat local des
jeunes ont aussi des idées à faire
valoir surtout quand on voit que
évidemment la crise économique touche
particulièrement les jeunes donc on a
aussi notre mot à dire moi je pense que
ce qui est important à mettre en avant
c'est aider l'entrepreneur
l'entreprenariat des jeunes donc aider
les jeunes à monter l'entreprise avoir
confiance en eux et de se lancer
première réunion ce vendredi soir à
Versailles entouré de leurs aînés à
l'image de Pierre Le Guérinel premier
adjoint amour pas venu délivrer quelques
conseils conseils
la ténacité
les échecs du moment ne sont pas des
échecs sont des obstacles qu'il faut
surmonter en particulier les premières
élections puis un peu de colère
il faut être un peu en colère pas
accepter le monde tel qu'il est ça c'est
aussi le bon carburant en attendant de
se mettre en colère l'UDI jeune des
Yvelines cherche à rassembler
actuellement la fédération compte une
vingtaine d'adhérents et pourrait
proposer des débats en septembre